l'obligation de port du masque a été
étendue aux enfants d'au moins six ans
depuis novembre 2020
il semblerait que chez les enfants il
peut être mal sur portet et représenter
les désavantager difficulté
[Musique]
oms a listé plusieurs effets
indésirables liés au port du masque
comment peut-il percevoir les émotions
de son interlocuteur lorsque la moitié
du visage de ce dernier est gâchée pour
les enfants de 6 à 11 ans qui sont
masquées quasi toute la journée les
risques physiologiques et psychologiques
sont importants beaucoup d'entre eux
souffrent déjà de maux de tête
saignements de nez difficultés à
respirer
angoisse phobie troubles de l'attention
du comportement tu rappelle que la
semaine dernière encore dans notre pays
20% des contaminations étaient que
concerner des mineurs ce n'est pas
encore venu le moment de pouvoir lever
le masque chez les enfants mais croyez
moi dès que nous pourrons le faire nous
le ferons et je pense que nous serons
bien qu'une année devant le parlement
pour que nous en féliciter